bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france comment est ce que vous avez reçu
cet appel à l'aide du patron d'
association internationale du transport
aérien
moi c'est vraiment scandaleux une honte
la loi est là pour protéger les plus
faibles
et dans ce cadre là on peut pas accepter
de modification de la loi au moment où
ça les arrange ou l'état a donné 7
milliards d'euros à air france et malgré
tout ils annoncent des licenciements
on voit très bien que dès qu grosses
compagnies comme air france utilise la
situation ducobu 19 puisqu'elle fait des
plans de départs volontaires depuis plus
de dix ans et faire des licenciements
direct maintenant un sous prétexte du
coc vide
et quand on voit que le citoyen mais
déjà la main à la poche
le fait de demander aux aux passagers de
ne pas être remboursés est vraiment une
honte
est ce que cette hausse du cgdd
aujourd'hui les compagnies aériennes en
entend moins parler
du rôle des actionnaires qui pourraient
eux aussi être invités à faire un effort
est tout à fait mais déjà pour beaucoup
le prix des billets est un
investissement lourd pour le revenu d'un
ménage c'est souvent un grand un grand
un grand sujet on met de côté de
l'argent pour pouvoir voir faire un
voyage mariages ou autres le fait que
l'argent ne soit pas redistribué aux
voyageurs profite forcément aux
compagnies qui elles le font travailler
sur les marchés boursiers très
concrètement vous l'avez évoqué
évidemment mais quelles sont les
répercussions aujourd'hui de ses
difficultés financières des compagnies
aériennes sur les salariés depuis le
début de la crise et au sortir de cette
crise sanitaire
là actuellement on fait déjà reposer
toute la crise sur le citoyen le citoyen
salariés le salarié est en chômage
partiel et déjà payés par l'état
donc c'est de l'argent public les
compagnies aériennes ne paye que très
peu de revenus de chaque salaire donc
c'est vraiment le citoyen qui paye les
salaires des compagnies aériennes merci
beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions rodolphe robert
je rappelle que a délégué syndical cgt
d'aéroport toulouse blagnac